like what is that what is that that
someone in this life comes in with this
ability to connect and
come out of your own experience and body
into another space another another
energy uh what is that
well it's a mystery isn't it you know
you see it a lot actually you see it in
artists and uh performers
yeah something comes through them
that they can't manifest something even
joyful and creative and and very
positive
but in their own lives they can't
manifest at all
but when they're when they're performing
it it just happens
I think that has to do with us some
people are born very sensitive and they
just connect
more naturally with [ __ ] outside
themselves
um
I also think it comes through
certain degree of suffering that maybe
you've worked through
you know
and also I think you know
this is getting maybe more mystical than
I usually would venture into but
there is a truth there's a larger Unity
that there's a Oneness that whether we
know it or whether we don't know it but
we all belong to and that can manage
that it manifests itself through us even
if our conscious mind and even our
personalities can't quite get a hold of
it I think I think that's what that's
what's going on yeah and it's beautiful
I would agree is there anything that you
do that gets you into that space more or
allows for more of that to come through
um a situation you put yourself in or a
practice that you have
[Music]
um
I'm not disciplined enough to have a
regular practice I mean I really do have
an 80 I really do have an 80d brain and
then it you know
it's a challenge for me to meditate or
to do yoga regularly for example when I
do but I don't keep it up as much as I
know would be good for me
for me that has come through psychedelic
work actually
um which is
not the same I mean as as just coming to
it
more spontaneously but that is that has
put me in those spaces sometimes and
that's been helpful for me yeah yeah I'm
glad you brought that up because I I
definitely want to ask you about that
um I've done it myself a few different
times
um Ayahuasca psilocybin yeah and dma
very varying degrees of healing tools
um
man is this the future of therapy is
this the future of
psychology and growth and meeting
ourselves uh I think that a loss of self
is something you've said has been is a
problem in society and what keeps us
disconnected from from ourselves that
loss of self through the environment
that we're in these days so psychedelics
essentially bring you back to that and
go beyond it into spaces my experience
that you don't you didn't know were
there
um aspects of yourself truths that you
wouldn't have always Otherwise Known so
it seems like this could be a really a
big healing tool moving forward
yes so in this book The Myth of normal I
do have one chapter on psychedelics
which is probably appropriate so out of
33 chapters one is on psychedelics
because I don't want to put my ex all
into the Psychedelic basket so like on
the one hand
it can be very powerful and the first
time I did I asked maybe 12 13 years ago
I just experienced this pure love that
had I that had never accessed before you
know I literally had tears of love
uh rolling down my cheeks and uh I
thought I'd arrived somewhere well
because my family could tell you two
days later
I had to Glimpse something but I hadn't
arrived anywhere you know so uh and I've
I've LED Retreats and I've helped people
with psychedelics and I've done
you know with myself I think they're a
great potential I don't think they are
the answer I don't think they are the
future I think the future has to be far
more with the transformation of people
and of social structures and the culture
itself we can't rely on one particular
modality but the psychedex to do is they
offer they show you a great potential
and
um
what shows up is As you say is things
you weren't aware of it's almost like
there's a membrane between our conscious
minds and all the stuff we carry in our
subconscious
and the psychedelics remove the membrane
it's almost like you can have a waking
dream and experience
overage or the hatred maybe all the
terror all the fear but all the beauty
all the love all the Oneness all the
unity all the joy all the presence that
is in US
and but be awake for the experience and
be able to get a relationship to it uh
psychedelics I think as you also suggest
I think
can put in touch with that Unity that
we're all a part of but we're hardly
aware of it most of the time in fact in
this culture which is all about
competition and aggression greed and
acquisition we are almost
societally
propagandized into forgetting that unity
and that Oneness and that
intercorrection Executives can open that
up beautifully
but
then is the rest of Life yeah and what
you glimpsed and experienced in the
secular space
the question is how to make those same
values which
people can attain with us like how to
make those values work in our regular
lives in our social lives in our culture
and that that's the question that goes
Way Beyond psychedelics I think
sure that's culture and society and the
patterns that they keep us in outside of
ourselves that pull us back in so
quickly what do you think holds us back
the most when we come out of that like
we we get into these spaces we feel love
and then we get back into our routine
like if there were a few things to
change what would it be like when you
came back what what did you think this
this is this is what Society pulls me
back into the heart with with the
hardest
I think there's two forces pulling us
back into our ordinary less Unitarian
less connected self
one is just
um our personalities are formed in the
first place
which is very often in my contention the
result of responses to traumatic events
or traumatic pressures that happen to
children in this Society quite a lot
and so we formed these defensive
structures that we call their
personality and the personally doesn't
want to give up too easily because
when stuff happened in childhood that
makes you defensive it makes you afraid
or makes you
um disconnected
um those structures have been living in
you and dominating your life
depending how old you are for for
decades they don't just disappear
they're not just dissolved you might get
a momentary respite from them in a
second space but they haven't all of a
sudden evaporated in the Buddha talked
about what he called our habit energies
so our habit energies are the thoughts
and emotional patterns and
psychological structures that
ingrained in our brains and our nervous
systems and our bodies and it just
reassert themselves almost automatically
then there's society which is
all about
how we look to others and what other
people think of us and how we fit in and
how we please others or how to compete
with others and
then we go back into that world and so
it's no wonder that between the inner
habit energies that have dominated our
lives and then the external pressures we
quickly can lose the glow of that
spiritual or psychological insight that
we gained either through some spiritual
experience or through secular like sort
with an encounter with nature perhaps so
it's difficult to maintain that and then
above all there's what my friend the
psychiatrist Dan Siegel calls the
um the the myth of the solo self and
like we all fundamentally every ego
believes that it's a UNIF that it's a
separate unit
sufficient unto itself you know and we
believe in our separateness and in this
culture
reinforces that belief of course so it's
it's not an easy not an easy path man
that brings me back to um so I did a a
little bit of a hero's dose of
psilocybin I took five grams and it took
me
a really distant place and I went really
far away but one of the main things that
happened in the experience was that and
it was facilitated this was this was
with a facilitator and yeah
um was that
I knew that being human wasn't real and
but I wanted to be human
yes and so the first thing that I had to
agree to in order to build constructs to
get back to being human was I had to
agree to the mind
yeah that's right and I was like great
okay perfect fine let's go I want I want
to see my family again I want to see my
dogs again
um because in the early part of the
experience I didn't know how I was ever
going to be human again because I knew
it wasn't real and so so yes I had to
agree to the mind which in you know for
for me felt like the ego it felt like
the stories this was the lie because
being human wasn't real the mind was the
LIE which is the stories and the ego
yeah have you ever experienced anything
like that
not personally but I can tell you about
somebody I talked to yesterday you might
know the name her name her name is Anita
more Johnny do you know that name no
okay
wrote a book
um
called dying to be me and
um here was a woman who no in my view of
illness as a physician I've noticed who
gets sick and who gets chronic illness
and malignancy it's people who really
repress themselves in order to fit in
with others and that's
defensive response to Childhood
experiences Anita was one of these
people
and she had this terminal lymphoma stage
falling lymphoma she was in a coma and
the doctor said this is in you know she
lives in L.A which is where I'm right
um she was in a coma and the doctors
ever telling her family to prepare for
her death within a few hours oh my
goodness and then Anita had this out of
body near-death experience
where she saw her whole life where she
saw her she had never been herself her
whole life that's why the title of a
book dying to be me it took near death
to make her become herself
but then she was in this realm where she
could have chosen to stay there
but she had to make a decision
do I stay there in this beautiful realm
of unity and Light
or do I come back into my mind and my
body and sounds very similar to your
experience you have that choice too she
said I made she said I made a choice to
come back now within four or five days
her lymphoma had disappeared and within
a few days she was out of hospital and
she's never been sick since
now this is not totally unheard of and I
can sort of explain it in certain
physiological ways but the point is she
was facing that same choice that you had
made and she just decided to come back
[Music]